[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الحلقه الجديده
من مستقبل الطاقه هذه ملفاتنا
140 مليار متر مكعب من الغاز تحرق سنويا
في الحقول العالميه والعراق من اكبر
المتضررين
[موسيقى]
والحقيقه هو حق الغازي
لانتاج ما يزيد على 400 مليون قدم مكعب من
الغاز
وزير النفط العراقي يكشف من الرياض عن
دخول ارامكو في تطوير حقل عكاز للغاز
[موسيقى]
صوره شعله النيران التي تعلو ابار النفط
هي الرمز التقليدي للتلوث والمخاطر الصحيه
التي يتسبب بها انتاج النفط لكن الدول
النفطيه تتفاوت بشكل كبير على هذا الصعيد
عندما تكون الشعله ملتهبه بشكل كبير فهذا
يعني ان الكثير من الغاز يحرق هنا الامر
يتعلق بمستوى الاستثمارات في استخلاص
الغاز المصاحب لانتاج النفط والاستفاده
منه اما لتشغيل محطات الكهرباء واما كلقي
من في صناعه الباتروكيماويات في عام 2022
تراجع احراق الغاز المصاحب عالميا بنسبه
ثلاثه في المئه الى 139 مليار متر مكعب
على الرغم من ارتفاع انتاج النفط بنسبه 5%
في الفتره نفسها ونتيجه لذلك انخفض معدل
احراق الغاز عالميا في حقول النفط من
الواحد في المئه الى
4.7% بحسب تقرير رصد احراق الغاز الذي
يصدره البنك الدولي هناك تسع دول مسؤوله
عن
74% من كميات الغاز التي يتم احراقها
عالميا اكبرها روسيا والعراق وايران
والجزائر وفنزويلا والولايات المتحده
تشير تقديرات البنك الدولي الى ان التخلص
من حرق الغاز في حقول النفط يتطلب
استثمارات بنحو 100 مليار دولار وهنا يبرز
دول التي حققت تقدما على هذا الصعيد
اللافت ان السعوديه التي هي من بين اكبر
ثلاثه منتجين للنفط في العالم لا يظهر
اسمها اصلا بين اكبر 10 دول في احراق
الغاز بل ان لديها اقل نسبه كثافه للاحرار
بين 30 دوله منتجه للنقل وهذا يعود
للاستثمارات الضخمه
للاستثمار وتحويلها في الغاز المصاحب في
صناعه
الباتروكيماويات تحديدا وقطاع الطاقه
[موسيقى]
يستورد العراق كميات من الغاز الايراني
تصل قيمتها الى سته مليارات دولار سنويا
فيما تحرق كميات اكبر من ذلك في ابار
النفط بسبب نقص الاستثمارات في الغاز
المصاحب فهل يكون هذا القطاع احد مجالات
التعاون مع السعوديه صاحبه افضل سجل عالمي
في هذا المجال
هذه النيران المشتعله على الدوام في
العراق تحرق كميات هائله من الغاز تقدر
بمليارات الدولارات سنويا فيما يستورد
الغاز من ايران لتشغيل محطات الكهرباء
اساس المشكله ان ابار النفط تحتوي على
كميات كبيره من الغاز المصاحب ومن الضروري
اخراجها لالا يرتفع الضغط داخل البئر
ويؤدي الى انفجارات هناك طريقتان لفعل ذلك
اما استخراج هذا الغاز والاستفاده من
قيمته الاقتصاديه في انتاج الكهرباء او
كلقيما لصناعه البتروكيماويات واما احراقه
وتحمل التلوث الناجم عن ذلك مشكله الخيار
الاول انه يتطلب استثمارات كبيره يقدرها
البنك الدولي ب 100 مليار دولار للتخلص من
حرق الغاز بالكامل على المستوى العالمي
كما انه يتطلب خبرات لا تتوفر في الكثير
من الدول
يحرق العراق 18 مليار متر مكعب من الغاز
سنويا بحسب بيانات البنك الدولي لعام 2021
بينما يستورد من ايران عشره مليارات متر
مكعب لتشغيل محطات الكهرباء وفق بيانات
2020 ويعد العراق ثالث اكثر دوله في
العالم احراقا للغاز بعد روسيا وايران
خسائر العراق من حرق الغاز واستيراده تقدر
بنحو 12 مليار دولار سنويا بحسب تصريح
سابق لمستشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي مظهر
صالح ومن ضمن هذه الخسائر فاتوره استيراد
الغاز من ايران لتوليد الكهرباء والتي تصل
الى سته مليارات دولار بحسب الارقام
المعلنه من وزاره الكهرباء العراقيه
لدى العراقي مشاريع ضخمه للتوقف عن حرق
الغاز تماما خلال اربع سنوات وقد توصلت
بالفعل الى اتفاقتين مع شلوه توتال في هذا
الاطار وفي اطار العقد مع هذه الاخيره
ستتم دعوه شركه اكوا بارك السعوديه
للمشاركه فيه في الشق المتعلق باستخدام
الغاز لانتاج الكهرباء
استغلال الغاز المصاحب يبرز كاحد مجالات
التعاون الممكنه بين السعوديه والعراق
وهذا ما اشار اليه وزير الخارجيه السعودي
فيصل بن فرحان خلال زيارته الى بغداد في
فبراير الماضي السعوديه لديها سجل عالمي
مرموق في كفاءه استغلال الغاز المصاحب فعل
الرغم من كونها على الدوام بين اكبر ثلاثه
منتجين للنفط في العالم الا انها تتفوق في
معدل حرق الغاز بشكل كبير على المنتجين
الاخرين الكبار روسيا والولايات المتحده
فبحسب تقرير بيبي سنوي وهو من اهم مصادر
البيانات المعتمله عالميا لم يتجاوز حرق
الغاز في السعوديه
2.7 مليار متر مكعب في 2021 مقابل
26.4 مليار متر مكعب في روسيا وتسعه فاصله
سبعه مليار متر مكعب في الولايات المتحده
في حين ان كمياتي انتاج النفط متقاربه في
الدول الثلاث كما تظهر السعوديه في تقليد
للبنك الدولي كافضل دوله نفطيه من حيث
كفاءه استخلاص الغاز المصاحب بدلا من
احراقه وهذا ما يفتح فرصا للتعاون بين
المملكه ودول المنطقه في مجال يخبئ فرصا
بمليارات الدولارات
[موسيقى]
اعلان مهم من وزير النفط العراقي حيان عبد
الغني على هامش اجتماع المجلس التنسيقي
السعودي العراقي في الرياض عن اتفاق لدخول
شركه ارامكو السعوديه لتطوير حقل عكاز
للغاز في العراق وذلك لانتاج اكثر من 400
مليون قدم مكعب من الغاز يوميا كما كشف
الوزير العراقي عن مباحثات لشراء الكهرباء
من السعوديه بما يصل الى الف ميجاوات
وانشاء اكبر محطه للطاقه الشمسيه في
العراق لكتواصل
لمن مده طويله مع الاخوه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الهدف من هذا التواصل هو
لدخول الشركات السعوديه في تطوير القطاع
النفطي وجرت مفاوضات سابقه كثيره مع سمو
الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان في هذا المجال
وكان هنالك
لاحظنا هنالك استجابه
لهذه لهذه الدعوات
واخيرا يعني تم الاتفاق يعني ضمن هذا
المجلس العراقي التنسيقي السعودي الى دخول
شركه ارامكو في تطوير احد العقول النفطيه
والحقيقه هو حق الغازي
لانتاج ما يزيد على 400 مليون قدم مكعب من
الغاز لتزويد الشبكه الوطنيه بالغاز
اللازم لتوليد الطاقه الكهربائيه كذلك
يعني
من خلال هذا المؤتمر
يعني اطلقنا جولتين من التراخيص
الجوله الخامسه والجوله السادسه الهدف من
هذه الجوله هو استثمار وتطوير عدد من
الحقول والرقع الاستكشافيه في المناطق
الشرقيه والغربيه
من العراق هذه الرقع تتضمن والحقول تتضمن
كميات كبيره من الغاز
يعني انها عباره عن حقول غازيه وبعض
الحقول النفطيه هذا الغاز ان شاء الله
نامل من مشاركه الشركات السعوديه لتطوير
هذه الحقول وانتاج الغاز المطلوب لتوليد
الطاقه الكهربائيه وسد الحاجه المحليه من
هذه من هذا الغاز اضافه لذلك تضمن
الاجتماع عدد من الفعاليات الاخرى التي
تخص موضوع الطاقه وعلى راسها تحويل كميه
من
الطاقه الكهربائيه الى العراق
بكميه تصل الى الف
وكذلك قيام الشركات السعوديه ان شاء الله
بانشاء محطه لتوليد الطاقه الكهربائيه
باستخدام الطاقه الشمسيه في محافظه النجف
الاشرف وهذه المحطه ستكون اكبر محطه في
العراق
باستخدام الطاقه الشمسيه بطاقات تصل الى
الف ميجا واط كذلك تم الاتفاق مع الاخوه
في المملكه
لانشاء بعض المدن الصناعيه
في الحدود في الحدود المشتركه بين
البلدين وهذه يعني سوف تساهم في تطوير
الصناعه والتجاره في كلا البلدين وهنالك
احد المشاريع المهمه ايضا التي
تم مناقشتها في في هذه الاجتماعات وهو
مشروع النبراس للبتروكيمياويات مشروع
النبراس للبتروكيميات يعتبر من اكبر
المشاريع البترو كيمياويه في المنطقه
لانه يستخدم كميات كبيره من
الغاز غاز الايثين اللي تصل الى 170 مليون
قدم مكعب وبالتالي هنالك رغبه كبيره
لاحظنا من قبل الشركات السعوديه للدخول
كمشاركين في هذا المشروع ان شاء الله
المباحثات بين السعوديه والعراق لشراء
الكهرباء تاتي بعد انطلاق مشروع الربط
الكهربائي بين دول الخليج والعراق والذي
بدء تنفيذه عام 2022 والذي سيمكن العراق
من تنويع مصادر شراء الطاقه وتخفيف
اعتماده على شراء الكهرباء من ايران
الرئيس تنفيذي لهيئه ربط الكهربائي
الخليجي احمد الابراهيم اكد لمستقبل
الطاقه ان الربطه الكهربائي بين دول
الخليج والعراق سيدخل مرحله التشغيل نهايه
العام المقبل
عن مشروع ربط العراق ومشروع استراتيجي
يهدف الى دعم التعاون بين التعاون
وجمهوريه العراق بدانا في تنفيذ المشروع
منذ العام 2020 واحنا ماشيين الحمد لله في
عمليه التنفيذ بشكل مستمر نتوقع ان شاء
الله ان المشروع يدخل في حيز التشغيل معنا
نهايه العام المقبل وبالتالي سوف نستطيع
في البدايه من تصدير طاقه تصل الى 50
ميجاوات الى جنوب جمهوريه العراق ومد
الطاقه اللازمه بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك خطط
لتوسيعها على المدى البعيد واحنا نحن نعمل
يعني جانبا مع
الجانب العراقي لوضع خطه طويله المدى
لتطوير هذا الربط ان شاء الله الرابط يكون
ان شاء الله هذا المرحله الاولى ولكن في
المستقبل سوف يكون بسعه اكبر ويخدم يعني
اهداف اكبر ان شاء الله على كم مرحله على
كم سنه ممكن يمتد هذا
المرحله الاولى يعني تمتد سنتين
اللاحقه سوف تكون يعني اكبر واحنا الان في
صدد
النقاش ووضع خطه العمل بهذا الخصوص قد
تكون خلال اربع خمس ادوات القادم ان شاء
الله وما هي النقاط يعني من اين يربط هذا
المشروع حاليا طبعا المشروع يربط شبكه
الربط الكهربائي الخليجي من محطتنا اللي
في دوله الكويت اللي تابعه لهيئه ربط
الكهربائي انشانا محطه جديده محطه الوفره
هي محطه جديده تهدف لي اولا توسعه الربط
الكهربائي مع دوله الكويت وايضا تكون نقطه
انطلاق للربط مع جمهوريه العراق سوف تكون
هذه في يعني تابعه لهذا الرابط في دوله
الكويت ومن جهه الجمهوريه العراق سوف تكون
في محطه الفاو في جنوب جمهوريه العراق ان
شاء الله بالنسبه لربط السعودي العراقي هل
هناك اي تطورات بالنسبه لهذا الربط طبعا
هناك عده ربوطات يعني هناك مثل ما احنا
نربط بجنوب العراق هناك ايضا مناقشات بين
يعني المملكه العربيه السعوديه وجمهوريه
العراق خصوص هذا الربط ان شاء الله ويعني
حسب ما علمنا ان شاء الله ماشي
وسكون الربط اخر وقوي ان شاء الله يربط
يعني بغداد بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه وكل
هذه الروبوتات ان شاء الله تصب في
منطقه واحده وهي دعم التعاون باللون
التعاون وجمهوريه العراق
نتوقف الان مع فاصل قصير نتابع بعده في
مستقبل الطاقه
هل تتقدم التكنولوجيا بالسرعه الكافيه
للوصول الى صافي صفربعاثات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الوصول الى صافي صفر
انبعاثات يتطلب تطوير تقنيات بعضها ما زال
في المراحل الاولى من التطوير وبعضها
الاخر في مرحله النماذج التجريبيه وكثير
منها غير مؤكد النجاح حتى الان سالت رئيسه
قطاع التكنولوجيا في ادنوك صوفي هلدر
براند عما اذا كان بالامكان او بامكان
تقنيات الطاقه النظيفه ان تتقدم بالسرعه
الكافيه للوصول الى صافي صفر بعثه لنستمع
الى اجابتها
ولكن ما هي الممكنات القادره على تسريع
نشر تلك التقنيات واستخدامها في التطبيقات
المختلفه
ما هي المساحات اذا التي يجب ان يركز
عليها العالم جهوده التقنيه لتسريع عجله
التحول الى الطاقات النظيفه
ما هي بعض التقنيات الحديثه التي كشف عنها
النقاب مؤخرا عالميا التي لفتت انتباهك
اخيرا كيف تقوم ادنوك اليوم بتطبيق
التقنيات النظيفه بهدف خفض انبعاثاتها
وتقليصي بصمتها الكربونيه
بغداد
[موسيقى]
هي ارق ماده معروفه في العالم وهي مصنوعه
من طبقات من ذرات الكربون هي اقوى من
الصلب ب 200 مره لكنها خفيفه الوزن وشديده
المرونه كما انها موصل ممتاز للحراره
والكهرباء الجرافين لها فرص كبيره في
تطبيقات الطاقات الخضراء وتحول الطاقه ومن
التطبيقات الجديده تحويل غاز الميثان من
منتج ثانوي يتم حرقه في بعض الاحيان الى
انتاج وقود الهيدروجين والجرافين تعالوا
نتعرف اكثر عن هذه التقنيه من احدى
الشركات التي تعمل على تطوير هذا التطبيق
انا
[موسيقى]
لهذا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه من مستقبل
الطاقم نلقاكم في نفس الموعد الاسبوع
المقبل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات